florian vous vous êtes procuré un
faux-pas sanitaire vous allez nous
expliquer tous les rouages du business
parce que on en parle de plus en plus de
ça des faux-pas sanitaires si fabrice di
vizio même peut intervenir là dessus
avec grand plaisir aussi mais est-ce que
vous pensez que ça met en danger la
france on rit on n'a pas peur de le dire
le business des faux-pas se mettait dans
la france en danger nous dit nous chez
vous alors vous utilisez un faux pas
depuis combien de temps au flanc depuis
deux mois depuis deux mois comment ça se
passe bah moi je me voyais pas jeter en
passe sanitaires je n'avais pas envie de
l'acheter parce que pour moi le vaccin
il est pas sûr d'accord donc ne voyait
pas me faire vacciner donc décidé
d'acheter un pass sanitaires
je l'achetais je croyais je les payais
350 euros quand même 3 50 au début
c'était beaucoup plus cher au début ça
parlait en mille euros une des 100 euros
comme il a beaucoup sur marché qui
tourne en ce moment les prisons baisser
donc là en ce moment il ya un business
de fou sur les faux pas on peut tout
acheter des romans vous avez trouvez
vous ne faut pas ce que donc c'est pas
quand mais voilà comment commence avec
comment vous avez le débat promet axis
et un contact à moi qui connaît son
médecin de entre guillemets quartier qui
m'a qu'il fait après à plusieurs
médecins qu'ils font aussi l comment ça
se passe vous voulez quelqu'un
l'identité de quelqu'un de vacciner où
ils habitent non comment ça c'est notre
nom voir notre carte d'identité et carte
vitale on est déclarée à la cmu donc
comme ça c'est comme si vous aviez fait
un temps de ce qu'on avait fait une
brève accent bah oui on voit notre film
inverse mais comment ils font pour les
doses il va il met à côté vidal et
il n'y a même pas besoin non mais tu n'y
a même pas besoin on lui fait le passe
comme ça il se met d'accord avec le
médecin même pas besoin de vider quoi
que ce soit mais sa série
florian oui c'est eux qui gerland 2
après ils font ils font comme ils
veulent pour passer ça ils font comme
ils veulent et en fait vous rentrez
partout avec partout c'est un vrai pas
ce qui s'y passe est entassé un vrai
faux passe en fait c'est un vrai faux
pas sur l'application tout ce que tu
peux vite ouvrir mon carnet ont scanné
validé vous avez beaucoup de gens qui
utilisent ce genre de pratiques
elle connaît beaucoup et ça marche ça
passe par aller dans les restaurants
dans les impasses partout vraiment sans
problème non non vous savez pourquoi
parce qu on ne vérifie pas l'identité à
chaque fois parce qu'en général les noms
mais oui
saint vital est à mon sens votre
wii
à l'hôpital demain il va à l'hôpital il
est considéré comme quelqu'un qui a été
vaccinée de serment donc c'est pas donc
danger public attendu à florian bague
que c'est un inconscient qu'est-ce qui
les utilisent il comprend pas mais
attendez dans ce cas là aujourd'hui on
peut avoir des faux permis on peut avoir
des fonds mais toujours tout est faux
pas alors aujourd'hui je me retrouve
mois vaccinés avec un mec à côté de moi
qui soi-disant est vacciné et ne l'est
pas
alors il y avait été vraiment esther
entre venu tester avant moi obligé de me
faire tester bien sûr donc j'ai accepté
mais mais est-ce que ça c'est vrai que
vous êtes un danger pour j'ai quelque
chose à dire à l'isic mais si vous êtes
vacciné oui je vais le signer mais quand
même être porteur du conte vide oui mais
c'est aussi les meules transmettent
alors logiquement huit fois moins qu'en
du tourment et nous ça nous avec un test
négatif monsieur vous savez qu'on peut
avoir des tests négatifs être enfournés
gala si tu as certainement période
d'incubation donc vous êtes aussi
dangereux mais jean louis c'est ce que
tu veux réagir là-dessus mon fabrice
non
ah ben si bien dit
alors là
l'argent je suis pas d'accord je ne suis
pas d'accord moi j'aimerais l'entendre
pour la première fois là dessus et ce
qu'ils veulent et veut pas parler il
veut pas parler c'est justement choisi
quelqu'un paris on
pose une question des problèmes alors
pas posé la question est-ce que vous
validez ce qu'a fait mentionner ce genre
doivent absolument pas et si vous
écoutez ce que je dis depuis le début si
vous lisez ce que j'écris j'écris qu'en
fait il est absolument hors de question
je vais vous dire moi obtenir un
faux-pas sanitaire ça me prend deux
minutes si je veux 2 minutes 30 pas plus
il est hors de question hors de question
que je cautionne ce type de comportement
hors de question je combats le système
je juge pour juger qui que ce soit mais
je suis à l'extérieur je combats le
système voilà de manière parfaitement
légale dire mais je refuse si vous
voulez d'abord d'entrer dans
l'illégalité il en est pas question et
ce en second lieu je refuse moralement
si vous voulez et c'est important de le
dire quand même de venir
mettre des gens en danger parce que
concrètement il n'est pas question c'est
vrai que il a raison monsieur sur le
fait que vous voulez d'ici que les
personnes vaccinées peu importe soit
deux fois moins huit fois moins un peu
importe la salle débat le débat c'est
que si j'obtiens vacciner je fais
vacciner si je ne veux pas me faire
vacciner et bien alors j'accepte les
contraintes qui sont liées à l'absence
de vaccination a raison
alors donc à ce moment-là plus en
liberté oui vous êtes hors la loi oui
charles alors mais moi je peux pas dire
que j'ai acheté un pass adducteurs pour
moi j'ai que c'est comme si j'avais
acheté ma liberté en fait moi je suis
jeune j'ai 20 ans j'ai envie de sortir
sauf que la liberté monsieur ne s'achète
pas elle est tout le temps gratuite
tous en même temps on a le temps se
calme pardon vous faites tous les chocs
et là vous êtes des millions de français
qui font ça
donnait
des as ouais c'est pas parce que 38
millions de mac soit la même connerie
que c'est pas une connerie non
parce qu'en fait il est tellement
absurde qu'il a transformé des millions
de gens très honnête en hors-la-loi mais
la vraie question qu'on doit se poser
city sont les hors la loi les gens qui
usurpe dépassent des débats sanitaire où
les gens qui les imposent c'est ça la
vraie question
florian vous avez beaucoup de potes qui
font ça comme vous oui et valais et ckoi
là c'est quoi la mode qu'on risque si
vous faites attraper elle est dérisoire
du tout 130 135 5 euros la tonne en 35
euros si on a un faux pas ce nom fabrice
complets annoncés 600t showbiz s'appelle
un fou et tucson c'est une peine
d'emprisonnement prison' m'en faire
attention d'accord ce 35 euros c'est si
vous ne présentez pas le pass est en
l'occurrence effectivement là on est sur
une on est sur une infraction pénale que
de faux en écriture si vous regardez
ces mois d'emprisonnement et 3750 euros
d'amendé ça peut aller jusqu'à 4,5 me
alors oui matt et moi je m'en fous de la
demande moi ce que voilà pourquoi je
suis c'est très très grave ce que vous
faites il ya deux façons des grandes
sociétés le passé n'étaient on est
vaccinés ou sinon on fait à insert tous
les trois jours je pense pas que vous le
fassiez sinon qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que si tu est porteur tu
vas croisé quelque part où c'est déjà
peut-être fait une vieille dame dans la
rue ou quelqu'un qui est malade et qui
elles vont mourir c'est à dire qu au
moment où je parle aujourd'hui tu as
peut-être déjà tué quelqu'un où il ya
quelqu'un qui est très très très malade
et tu ne sais pas
sinon nous il faut à moins de chance de
le donner mais vous annoncions excusez
moi c'est qu'il n'est pas un test tous
les jours quand tu vas troisième vieille
dame ou quelqu'un de fatigué quelqu'un
l'a tué
pensant que comme il en riant pas
sanitaire vous n'avez pas besoin de
faire de test pour le coc vite vous
pouvez dans le temps plus d'an nabi fois
moins 90% de chances de moins de le
transmettre canton et dax in et même si
on l'a que quelqu'un qui n'est pas
fabriqué le monde
pourquoi ces débats sont sous l'eau
descend pas selon vous êtes acheter la
nation c'est vous comprenez rien ils
sont supplantés moi pourquoi vous êtes
sous lampe à ce que vous racontez
n'importe que ses doigts alors c'est
matthieu delormeau et et qu'elle met
vous avec moi
[Applaudissements]
liberté et j'ai absolument aucune leçon
à recevoir de vous vu effectivement les
conneries que vous débitez à longueur
d'émissions à l'étranger et m adresse
monsieur on n'est pas libre en soucier
en bas sinon j'adore rouler à 300 alors
sur l'autoroute
atteinte à ma liberté alors vous allez
mieux ces verrous les violences
vous voulez bien évité d'employer des
mots dont deux contre des pales sont ce
qu est ce que vous y connaissez à la
liberté mais vous aurez que toi contre n
importe quoi deux minutes à venir faire
des débats philosophiques le seul mec
libre ici pardon mais c'est moi parce
que moi j'assume jusqu'au bout en fait
et je viens pas effectivement vous
donner des leçons qu'elle quelle soit
vous passez votre temps à donner des
leçons
non mais attendez vous passez votre
temps à donner des leçons à tout le
monde moi j'ai dit ce monsieur est
effectivement que je ne cautionnais pas
ce qu'ils faisaient mais je n'ai aucun
jugement à porter parce que duke
guillaume genton est vrai quand vous
avez des mesures absurdes quand vous
avez vu complètement con faut pas vous
étonner que les gens réagissent de
manière conne enfin je veux dire à un
moment donné merde quoi papa sanitaire
est juste
enfin monsieur je suis qui draine non
c'est pas la question dans ce sens
là dessus je fais pas un truc que je
serai pas le siège était un truc que je
ferais pas la preuve que je suis libre
c'est que je vais pas débattre avec vous
je vais
parce que s'il ya bien un truc que j'ai
pas envie de faire c'est perdre mon
temps
on va laisser pas brice de minutes ce
combat là on va le rappeler là on est
sur florian florian qu'utilise si vous
nous rejoignez info passe est-ce que les
faux-pas sanitaire met la france en
danger il avait et dites nous ce que
vous en pensez vous delphine tu pense
que oui qu'on soit pour le vaccin ou
qu'on soit contre le vaccin en fait
chacun est libre de penser d'agir de
serre vacciner ou pas il faut juste
assumer par contre à lorient là ce que
tu fais ça veut dire tu ne voulais pas
de faire vacciner mais pense à tous ces
autres personnes effectivement qui comme
toi ne voulait pas se faire vacciner du
coup tu vas aller dans les lieux où ces
gens là ne seront pas vaccinés ils
auront effectivement faire leurs terres
speisser tu peux leur refiler les trucs
et risquent en revanche de faire des
formes de gros risques en revanche
pardon de faire des formes graves donc
en fait tu penses pas aux gens qui
pensent comme as tu vois et là tu risque
de créer des clusters c'est hyper grave
en voulez de personnes veulent alors
regard regardez à quoi ressemble c'est
faux parce et regarder comment ça se
passe c'est regarder cette enquête
réalisée par la cellule investigation de
radio france à ses intérêts sans rien
j'ai trouvé un jeune homme qui s'appelle
corentin qui à 31 ans qui est éducateur
auprès des enfants et des adolescents en
difficulté il a eu par l'intermédiaire
de quelqu'un qu'il connaissait un numéro
sur un réseau social qui lui a demandé
300 euros il a donné son nom son prénom
sa date de naissance et son numéro de
sécurité sociale et quelques heures
après c'est simple il a reçu un mail
d'amélie avec sont un vrai foot leur
quotidien aux études et rinça
exactement aussi ça donc c'est 350 euros
350 euros que je les payais mois après
je pense qu'il ya d'autres prix mais moi
je les payais 350 alors c'est vrai que
il ya beaucoup de tricheurs à onze
longues et vous faites par rapport à
votre famille parce que du coup une
pensée est vacciné vous allez votre
famille votre famille est ce qu'elle est
vacciné pas du tout comment vous faites
non mais c'est pas la peine de soupirer
c'est exaspérant
j'ai seulement répondu j'ai enlevé j'ai
envie d'enlever des mois la question est
de dire est ce que le pass sanitaire met
la france en danger ce pas sanitaires il
fait en dépit en dépit du bon sens il
enfreint le secret médical il divise les
français qui passent le temps à se juger
arias insulté il allait parler en dépit
du bon sens résultats ya plein de gens
qui font défaut et surtout son
application sur le terrain elle est
impossible vous vous rendez compte qu'il
ya plein d'entreprises de petites
entreprises qui sont obligées
d'embaucher des gens pour contrôler des
passes sanitaire crois que c'est un
métier ça
et c'est le finir et moi on a droit les
discuter des lois
l'ancien gouverneur et la majorité des
campagnes êtes vous obligé dans la
minorité s'il vous plaît arrêtez de
parler comme oublié un point qui nous
parle comme tout le monde d'oublier
entendre ça nous a mis
tout le monde à supporter excusez moi
mais comme le monde oublie répond je
t'attends de mailer fabrice jouhaud prix
qu'est ce que c'est attendu que jamais
après fabrice non je sais je trouve que
tout est fait en dépit du bon sens et
que regarder les gens regardez à quel
point ça a divisé la société y aller
vacciner d'un côté les non-vaccinés de
l'autre et tous les fraudeurs à se faire
insulter regarder on en présente vous
avez
la liberté
réanimation de la liberté réanimation
les mots matures ne pas pas quand je
donne pas la parole lors de play mini
fabrice mercier isabelle la liberté
c'est laisser les gens vivre c'est le
sens que les gens sortir d'un été
voilà il ya plein de arrêtez avec vos
chiffres et de statistiques qu'il en
donne son rôle où il ya eu la liberté
c'est laisser juge tranquillement et se
passe tout le monde sait qu'il est
insupportable invivable et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des gens qui font défaut et
arrêter les traiter comme des criminels
s'ils
sont hors la loi mais mis sur la
rade aujourd'hui n'était pas la loi dia
il ya quinze jours oui mr la loi quand
même en hors-la-loi d'accord mais moi le
pas salutaire jeu là peut acheter par
dépit pour pouvoir sortir parce que je
me voyais pas me faire vacciner mais je
me voyais sortir quoi tu parce que moi
je suis si quelque chose a pour amant
son pardon j'ai juste une question
pourquoi est ce que tu ne vas pas en
faire il a partagé leurs projets un jour
il allait me faire explique qu'il est
droit dans ses bottes qui va jusqu'à une
démarche intellectuelle il dit qu'il
refuse à la fois la vaccination est à la
fois le pass annie terre donc il est
extrêmement cohérent et jusqu'au bout du
bout il est cohérent donc c'est pourquoi
est-ce-que et pourquoi est ce que vous
ne faites pas vous une sorte de
cohérence ou dites moi je ne veux pas et
auquel cas je m'inscris encore et je le
redis je reviens ce pacte citoyen en dix
ans dans le doute je veux pas
éventuellement contaminer les uns et les
autres donc je ferai que je n'ai pas
vacciner parce que je n'ai pas envie
mais je vais faire athena un test pcr je
pense que j'ai une conscience avant de
sortir d'aller en boîte ou d'aller
quelque part je vais quand même aller
faire un test pas content parce que j'ai
pas que ça à faire d'aller me faire
tester tous les deux jours ou si voilà
très turbulent mais rien au niveau lui
qui voulait dire un truc mais au-delà de
tout ça je pense qu'on a quelque chose
et je trouve ça dommage que vous êtes
pour la sq il a fait florian n'ont pas
forcément pour mais c'est pour ça que
voudrait m'exprimer sur les choses parce
que pour certaines choses là on parle de
sortir en boîte de nuit au restaurant
est ce qui s'en suit mais il ya autre
chose qu on oublie de dire et là du coup
je malheureusement c'est triste mais je
rejoins un petit peu les choses je vais
vous dire pourquoi il ya le journaliste
des milliers de salariés qui vont perdre
leur emploi et qui sont à la recherche
justement de faut juste pour pouvoir
nourrir leurs familles à travers ce
passe de la honte qui a été instauré
aujourd'hui en france parce qu'ils ont
peur du vaccin parce qu'ils ne veulent
pas se faire vacciner et on leur a pas
laissé le choix est en fait le choix je
suis désolé de le dire c'est de leur
dire à ces gens là vous allez perdre
votre temps vous perdez peut-être votre
maison ou finir est peut-être là la rue
avec vos enfants et bah ces gens là oui
aujourd'hui cherchent des défauts pas
sanitaires tout juste ou simplement pour
aller travailler et ça c'est dramatique
dans notre pays aujourd'hui sincèrement
et je prendrai dans mes justesse que là
on reste sur le truc parce que florian
vous comprenez donc ce qui peut faire
baver de son faux parce qu'ils soient
hors la loi ça vous le savez ça serait
bien d'être hors la loi mais aujourd'hui
malheureusement des gens je suis pas
d'accord avec fabrice sur ce qu'il va
dire où il dit la vérité s'achète pas
aujourd'hui dans notre pays et bien
malheureusement aujourd'hui j'en suis
pas si sûr qu'est-ce qu'on répond à
toutes ces personnes qui sont privées de
liberté privé de pouvoir aller
travailler qu est ce qu on leur répond
c'est quoi leur solution à moi je
voudrais solution qu'on peut leur
apporter un jeune homme alors septembre
ils seront licenciés fabrice elle répond
moi j'ai une réponse la radio c'est la
mienne c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est
très clair on combat pas un système en
venant finalement comment je vais dire
en venant jouer avec ses règles c'est
pas comme ça qu'on fait oui le pasa
nectar est absurde vous voulez un
exemple tout à l'heure je serai sûr btp
dans la cour alors j'ai appris depuis
lundi que la cour n'est pas soumise à
pas sanitaire figurez vous non j'ai
appris depuis lundi on m'a présenté des
documents officiels que la cour n'est
pas soumise à pas salutaire alors que si
j'étais sur une terrasse de restaurant
là je serai soumis à pas sanitaire alors
que si je suis sur un spectacle en plein
air là je suis soumis à passani terre
alors le mec qui me dit encore que ces
mesures sont sanitaire c'est soit qu'il
est aveugle soit qu'il est con fabrice
et moi ces mesures sont sanitaires bah
écoute et choisissez donc aux aveugles
ou con
mais choisir comme on
[Applaudissements]
n'a pas entendu gémir dès maintenant on
va pas on va pas parler du débat je ne
fais pas le débat avant sur le plateau
il irait là vous restez sur le pass
annie terre et surtout aurions bien sûr
mais ce que dit olive olive c'est
proprement scandaleux vous le dites avec
vos mots mais vous dites je ne suis pas
forcément pour au niveau livre il faut
être forcément contre parce que les
arguments des anti passe en ce moment
c'est de culpabiliser ceux qui sont dans
la loi ceux qui sont dans la norme ceux
qui ont eu le pass guillaume genton et
dangereux également parce que vous dites
vous dit notre liberté notre liberté
risqueurs moi je comprends mais là vous
parlez moi j'aime moi je vois là on peut
tous ne pas être d'accord mais guillaume
il parle qu'il donne son avis là vous on
a l'impression que vous parlez et vous
avez la bonne parole et vous êtes vous
avez raison parce que pas d'accord même
si c'est moi tu descendais ces lignes ou
non mais je suis désolé mais n'y ont pas
du tout guillaume donne son avis mais je
sais riga liste non mais payet jean
gilles c'est l'oeil à la taulada voilà
comme
on est d'accord que les hors la loi on
est con vient après chacun guillaume à
son avis vous avez votre avis mais là
vous êtes en train de vous faire un
score à courir et quand vous ne
condamnez pas les hors-la-loi
commerçants et s'est
excusé moi au niveau lillois dont vous
parlez kyo blagues y compris des
tests pcr idée il est dans la loi ceci
au mi décembre mais qui auraient loupé
moi j'avais la mairie donc j'appelle
saïda pendant six mois exactement voilà
ce monsieur en fait j'ai sonné par la
loi ce monsieur ne fait pas un faux pas
de sanitaires pour des besoins percière
et fais pas ça pour aller en boîte de
nuit il fait ça pour des besoins
primaires mais bien servi bien nommé
chat
je dis pas que je cautionne je dis que
ça ne m'étonne pas a dit que celles
aujourd'hui des gens à qui on dit soit
tu te fais vacciner soit tu es viré pour
qu'on parle quand même de besoins
primaires de travailler de vivre ça me
choque et joue sans comprendre quand on
est certain qu'ils le fassent